british foreign secretary on her first
official visit to moscow liz trust
followed diplomatic protocol by laying a
wreath at the tomb of unknown soldiers
close to the kremlin
a gray and cold days started the foreign
secretary's trip but it was an even
colder reaction from her russian
counterpart sergey lavrov following
their near two-hour session behind
closed doors
i'm the solution about the fact that our
conversation is like between a mute
person a deaf person demands to remove
russian troops from russian territory
kept coming up during all negotiations
it is regrettable as for ideologies
ultimatums and threats this is a
dead-end street and yield nothing
unfortunately some of our western
colleagues have been carried away with
this in their public statements i cannot
call this diplomacy
lavrov made it clear that the british
are not listening to russia's concerns
fundamentally a war in ukraine would be
disastrous for the russian and ukrainian
people
and for european security
and together nato has made it clear
that any incursion into ukraine would
have massive consequences
and carry severe costs
the british efforts to reduce tensions
continued in the belgian capital where
prime minister boris johnson met nato
secretary general jen stoltenberg both
presenting a united front against what
they say is russian aggression this is
probably the most dangerous moment
i would say in the course of the next
few days in what is the uh biggest
security crisis that
europe has faced for decades and we've
got to get it right and i think that the
combination of
sanctions and
military resolve
plus diplomacy
is what is in order
from brussels to warsaw in the same day
boris johnson visited the polish capital
to reiterate britain's resolve to
protect nato allies
another 250 british soldiers are due to
arrive in poland soon making it home to
the largest overseas deployment by
britain's armed forces a fact moscow
says is further evidence of nato's
eastward expansion liz trust came here
hoping to get some reassurances from her
russian counterparts but it seems her
visit may have caused more damage to the
fragile relationship between london and
moscow
the british defense secretary is due in
russia on friday no doubt hoping for a
better outcome
dorsojabari al jazeera
moscow mr vassen's in the belarussian
capital minsk with more on the start of
russia's military drills
russia is flexing its military muscle
right here in belarus kremlin has
already confirmed that this is not the
usual exercise this exercise called
allied resolve basically defending the
union state which involves russia and
belarus against what they say is a nato
imminent attack
the kremlin said it's an unprecedented
threat to the territory and that's why
the scale of this exercise is much
larger than the usual exercises these
countries will hold normally nato chief
has estimated 30 000 russian troops
forces are here now in belarus that
would be the largest deployment of
russian troops since the end of the cold
war and they're holding officially war
games basically a scenario that belarus
is being attacked by nato and its leader
is being toppled but this is all
happening just 50 kilometers away from
the ukrainian border and two hours away
from ukraine's capital kiev we have
sukhoi fighter jets involved s 400
missile defense systems it's a large
operation and as you said russia and
belarus are saying this is just an
exercise these forces will go home after
february 20 but there's a lot of
speculation if there's just maybe a
smokescreen for a real attack so there's
a lot of
anxiety about these exercises so to say